welcome to singapore a hub for
entrepreneurs pushing the boundaries of
technology here innovators are tackling
some of the most pressing issues of
today from sustainability to healthcare
and communication these technologies
have an impact that could make a
difference worldwide
this great big story was made possible
by the singapore tourism board singapore
economic development board and
enterprise singapore on the island of
singapore where city and nature coexist
researchers developed a small but mighty
solution to protect an essential natural
resource
the world is running out of access to
fresh water and that's where we want to
make an impact by utilizing an
environmentally friendly sponge to clean
the water and not to waste available
resources but to make them available for
recycling my name is andres dolz and i'm
the ceo and co-founder of ecoworth tech
this is the carbon fiber aerogel it's a
pure carbon super absorbent sponge that
has the ability to absorb a wide range
of organics and through simple
mechanical squeezing we're able to
recuperate and reuse those available
organics and also we're able to reuse
the sponge over and over again here in
the lab we produce the sponge via
controlled burning process we load the
furnace with the cellulosic material and
then we heat up the furnace so we end up
with a material that attracts oils
grease fats dies and repels water we
believe that in the future we can clean
up oil spills offshore so it's something
that we are very passionate to bring to
life and with that achieve big positive
environmental impact
in another lab scientists are brewing a
big idea that involves a certain pesky
insect with the key to preventing
diseases
over 40 percent of world's population is
at risk of dengue mosquitoes can spread
this disease if this problem isn't being
addressed the situation will become
worse with our innovative solutions we
are able to reduce the disease
mosquitoes in the community david du is
the co-founder of arena technology his
team with the help from singapore's
national environment agency has created
a system to help scientists breed male
mosquitoes they are injected with a
bacteria called walbukia and then
released into an environment to mate
with female mosquitoes causing them to
lay eggs that do not hatch many
companies want to use this technique but
counting as well as sorting the males
and females can be extremely laborious
the larvae dispensing system quickly
counts the larvae and the pupae
separation system sorts the sexes we
hope more industries could adopt our
technology to improve public health and
quality of life
helping people live a better life is at
the core of this next singapore-based
invention
it's all about giving an extra hand
due to aging population we have more and
more people with stroke causing physical
damage by using soft robotic
technologies we can make something new
that's very portable and easy to use my
name is jin wang i'm the co-founder and
ceo of processor technologies this is
called iso glove which is a soft robotic
hand glove for people with neurological
disorders and eventually may have hand
impairments we have selected one
specific material a very light fabric we
also have a control box to provide the
power and the air into the glove and
together with our software we are able
to provide hand rehabilitation therapy
so far we have been trying our device on
hundreds of patients in different
continents so we have seen very positive
outcomes from very mild patients all the
way to serious stroke patients there are
a lot of problems in the world
especially health care problems so if we
can utilize innovations to help people
recover much faster we can improve the
quality of life of all the people who
are affected with diseases or
disabilities
now onto a light bulb moment that's
bringing power to rural regions
more than 2 billion people
have very limited access to electricity
a lot of these people use kerosene lamps
there are many accidents that happen and
it's not very environmentally friendly
our solar lantern solves all these
problems my name is hari haram and i'm
the founder and ceo of third wave power
this is the solar lantern the solar
panel is the primary element that
actually collects energy it's exposed to
the sun and energy goes into the battery
the battery stores the energy during the
day when the lantern switches on the led
will start consuming the energy from the
battery we also use a battery technology
called the lfp batteries that lasts for
nearly four to five years so it's
definitely way more efficient way more
safe the impact that solar powered
applications can create in the future is
far greater than what we have achieved
today and it's only the beginning of the
journey
and finally a device that uses a
different kind of light to empower those
without access to what many people take
for granted there's a lot of areas in
the world that don't have good access to
internet simply because building
infrastructure in those places is too
expensive we believe everyone regardless
of where they're living should have
access to the internet that's why we're
building the centauri technology the
centauri one is a laser communication
device that can help people get access
to super fast internet it uses state of
the art laser communication technology
all you need to do is go on a rooftop
mount the device point it towards the
closest location nearby where you do
have access to internet you put another
one of these devices on that rooftop as
well the lasers will find themselves and
boom you have a fiber like connection
between the two buildings
our ultimate goal is to build a global
network of satellites using lasers to
connect every single place on the planet
to each other so that's the way we see
ourself growing in the future
connectivity for everyone
[Music]